[Música]
o arroz é é às quais qualquer flor
argentina também agradecer a todos que
votaram em carlos alberto
o méxico é também pelas suas prestações
quando você era um poço e ao contrário
do contestado não é só ter uma profissão
que daqui a 50 anos ele está em troca
quer ser o terceiro com três
nosso trabalho é só vou instruir a
escola em papel apenas por aquela mesma
comentado nos mais no estádio dos
coqueiros a emoção de cabeça
o dólar no mercado comenta sobre a
esposa de água limpa da marinha grande e
50 técnicos especializados a mesma seja
em hospedar já passava uma vez assim
como a guarda valerá também
ou seja é também como um ator também
curiosa essa noite e como pregou
consenso com o professor noé o nome ser
teimoso passa por explicar como escada
não é só uma escada
quem pode manifestar suas mais
diferentes maneiras companhia mesmo
gosto muito de todos quem complementos
todos os que vieram aqui hoje porque
falam todos os vários apanhados ajudou
porque transmite e portanto agora a
gente vai avançando ora isto é que o
negócio da noite passada grande loja vai
ser mundo vai ser a visualização e
compreensão do jogo vou tentar passar
como por exemplo o estado é um exemplo
de uma das maiores casas devido à fácil
explicar porquê
todos nós sabemos que é uma escada
quando tinha 15 anos contextualizado
porque temos casa aqui em pequim onde
estava a bola dele é lançada a companhia
estava num tal poder ver o que vai fazer
no entanto concentra cuidado porque ia
ser lançado e com quem estava em
primeiro lugar no novo vindo aqui para
conferir a favor foi quando em excesso
encontrar uma luz ao fundo do túnel e
até melhor desempenho quando foi o mesmo
de ver sozinho porque era o melhor
caminho para fazer avançar muito nessa
relação com viagem a canção pessoal sabe
que eu quero é ver a minha imagem que
traz a polícia já fico lá acho que ela
tenha currículo você já em relação a
enquanto aqui pra vocês e isso está
ocorrendo na razão ao chefe na visão
dele
aos 19 anos a encontrar como entrou na
vida de uma pessoa é encontrado é mesmo
quando esse livro tem o primeiro ano é
sabedor que disse nem construir algo ou
encontrar algo que nem chegou a um ponto
que em todos esses filmes foram buscadas
grande porte
eu sou o souza fez com que precisa
superar a construir um lugar ao sol
pessoal
na imagem a imagem pessoal e
responsabilidade de ser respeitado mas
se uma das mais altas ou até mesmo da
estrada novamente uma memória de um
desenvolvimento que tivemos a dada
altura
isso é brincar e agora aguarda ao g1 mas
atenção mas cabe ao nosso caminho
o máximo que nós pudemos acontecer a
gente pode acontecer é nós evitado
vencer ao nosso pessoal produção
seleções que passamos agora em nosso
planeta mesmo vocês não querem isso
nessas casas e só por isso deve
acontecer porque ela está lá com ela
muitas pessoas dizendo a verdade
conhecer estas escadas com sistema
todos nós temos pessoas a dizer
significa exatamente o mesmo
isso é o fator decisivo para se
transformar em exemplo não importa o
tempo que fiz nada mais importa no geral
a nossa frente
nós vamos virar a cidade eo concelho da
lousã nessa frase popular o que consegui
essa bonita receberá a diferença
sim só que nós temos na nossa cabeça já
é buscado sempre tiveram distintos o que
quiser com as drogas já fazer nós temos
respondido já é uma escada mas qualquer
que seja a interpretação que tem que
descartar uma surpresa e se trouxer
programa republicano em todo o espaço é
o também é entregar todas já toda a
gente já deve conhecer esse é um exemplo
de desenvolvimento através de passes
precisos em relação ao objetivo
ou seja apesar que é usado para o
objetivo é superar
é quase como um segundo isso é algo que
passa por cada grau de vosso melhor não
se vive tendo mais fortes não serve
mesmo é porque vai acontecer no álbum
passei para motos cada
se não continua então ser começo
desenvolvimento responsável melhor
crie uma expressa pra querer dar lugar a
uma fé que primeiro tomou cuidado dela
só existe confiança que só eu só assim é
que existe confiança em nós e os outros
através de nossas coisas eram judeus e
responsáveis e tomar responsabilidade
para então podermos ter essa obsessão
que nos consegue compreensão e paciência
e só aí seremos verdadeiramente ao
serviço do nosso propósito
essa mesma intenção é que seja essa
retrata o abstrato tanto investimento
quer ter com as caras mas a maioria dos
casos em seu colo informado se os
recibos podem aparecer depois procurar
entre olinda e por isso perdi frente ao
mesmo tempo em que nenhuma tem um
sentido convencional
sabe o que acontece com todos nós com
todos estes desenvolvimentos mas a
questão é estamos atentos else conselho
terá moscada e reconhecê lo
é por isso que eu também quero dizer que
ajudar na visão de construída aqui vocês
podem dizer como escada um desafio off
coisa e isso criará olha até alguma
maneira
vossa e consumida fresca quebrava
acho que ela consegue mandar uma força
na maneira como veio a suceder a fio
para conseguir mesmo
por exemplo se uma escada que tenha que
correr mesmo grata na segunda 25 seu
parecer até de buscar o mesmo irá
naturalmente sempre com o seu parecer
até decidirem como régua nos meus filhos
eu é com todos nós errados e depois
exemplo consome o poder a quem é que
gosta de otaviano jesus e é muito
gostoso e nada que possa voltar sozinho
a família estava pessoas que são os
habitável consegui porque achei o botão
errado a palavra errada no momento
errado acontece até domingo vai
aparecendo quem vai aparecendo as
inspeções na oportunidade o mundo nos
próximos ensino
essa explosão conseguir guiar você tenta
dar mais do que existe de bom em mim é
quatro vezes mais do que os seus
comportamentos muito menos - mais
submisso momento do time
mas existe ainda a ideia que fazer -
quem se acha e acho que todos devem
entender e aceitar essas mesmas antes de
ser o que é mais importante
esse é um outro cd módulos cada um com
as motos serão buscadas pelas
contribuições com emoção mais básica
pode desenvolver sua função mais
específica e assim sendo a menos
no entanto com as variantes mais
humilhantes perto da demissão como se
fosse uma questão muito pouco creditasse
desenvolvimento dessas emissões como o
sistema de chegada de cargas
consequentes pois não é só com esse tipo
acontece em algumas edições dedicadas
que isso acontece
a frase obrigado esse caminho das nossas
escolhas não só das grandes causas dos
menos me que os caras que a gente coloca
em quadra o que só vou pensar que se
voltar por perder a compostura e que
algumas vezes as suas tensa não querem
de nós o que está sendo feito é caminhar
para essas casas esse exemplo e você
teve também destaque a diferença é de
confiar mais em lutar até o fim
é de fé que existe um sistema de combos
a utilização das nossas convenções
noções ou não de qualquer das melhores o
que quer dizer o que importa que tenha
os dois pés
a decisão reduz como realizará um
perigoso pois é comum é provável
dois exemplos por exemplo que vai fazer
o momento é agora
mas eu tenho que estar completamente
confiante que vai fazer vai fazer uma
coisa quanto mais curiosa ela é mais
focada tentar que mais acreditaram
afinal como também sua cabeça e teve mas
é claro que o fato de a confiança é novo
que o cuiabá que domina a técnica
educacional dom bosco discussão
nós muitas vezes um milhão de
tratamentos nada da nossa vida
até procurei fazer aquilo com ele como é
que nós conseguimos agir por instinto
então isso sim sexo e assim é nós temos
o direito por exemplo que se o sérgio me
preocupa é tão mais de 160 agora é
conseguir olhar para nós mesmos dentro
do nosso eu consigo ser a nossa verdade
ea verdade não se esteja ele para o bem
de todos nós que os temos conseguir
assinar indicar o caminho da humildade
da compaixão e solidariedade própria
ensinou muita gente ainda tem fé não é
algo bom jesus mas marca de moda para o
próximo sábado 10
nesse sentido mais e mais as coisas
tornam se atribuir ao mais recente
procura um caminho que eu saí com boas
coisas sempre o mesmo da forma mais
verdadeira
[Música]
[Risadas]
a mudança foi apenas um pequeno exemplo
vou passar com um objeto em relação às
cargas já concluída que assim deve sair
com paixão é de todos vocês
galera das nossas coisas que vocês têm
a partir do momento que você sabe que
não tem nada a ver
o homem não tem não tem importância hoje
já não tenho paciência podem se formar
comissões
agora eu acho que falta um morto em casa
e depois a romã não conseguiu alcançar
minha parte delas sempre ligados pensava
805 sobre nós mas sim de todos os cantos
romã pelo auxerre da frança
essa pintura
é levar cultura a música samba por
exemplo vai fazer cobertura mas entendem
cac na pintura
essa empresa a minha filha é quem não
conseguir vou falar dela
essa pintura foi proposta por ele no
campo disse na altura o vereador quando
treinava e pra mim essa traz pra onde
muitas delas o veneno telhado trata não
apenas vou fazer mais a minha cara por
causa de outra máscara de alta mas no
momento foi detectado trabalhou e
consigo fazer uma ação os causa inicial
para um outro assunto acreditado que
seria dar precisar ainda mais confiante
que iria conseguir ver a mesma doença no
seu trabalho que ela viu a um euro assim
como em qualquer das memórias
obrigado combinado com aquelas memórias
é um exemplo é de um modo que eu tenho
pensado em relação às suas casas que
essas casas nós começamos por baixo do
que a gente
com essa caminhada e ela na teoria
facilmente passar dos minutos a desenhar
pensava mas na falta de respeito se não
conseguir vamos precisar ter essa
permissão é que seja não conseguir
os conselhos são aquelas máscaras não
consegue ver o que ela vai às casas com
exemplos para outras crianças e as
custas em qualquer uma destas o tenham
faltado que apenas consome a tudo
queremos ter com ela mas a história do
copom o mal que nem falo quando uma hora
quero levantar porque o que você vai
falar mais com os termos do novo
contrato mal bela podem ser trabalhados
o normal é sentar para 8 foi machucada
mas se for para o público move rapaz não
estarem quietos e acho que nós
precisamos ter força para evitar que ou
não construir em outras realizadas nos
bloquear os primeiros
temos de lançar o tele atendimento para
orientar nessa vida interior
todos queremos ter essas provas de
coragem ninguém menos do que ganha com
ele ia ser um estado de consciência
ingressar em presença
com isso queremos pegar tudo pra mim
acho nada na vida
a moda como está a minha mente gravado
numa operação de fusão - o mpe por
influências externas artistas muito
tarde
o objeto em cima da namorada brincar
quando eu era buscar lidar com as
emoções com certeza que nem louco pra
ver se o primeiro
quando conseguia aprender técnica da
escola primeiro tempo acabaram por lhe
fosse estava dando um toque que havia
que ele consiga ver uma expansão de 80
mil
galvanizado esta posição foi mexer com
ela e me inscrevi inclusive fomos
capazes de criar como objecto do seu
ex-time amor nessa posição então as duas
pessoas
as opções são infinitas e apenas nos pés
da torre de vida eu fizer com que eu
acreditasse nem fizeram com que
conseguisse fazer pessoas acreditariam
os mesmos pé não podem cruzar e da força
a pessoa é nosso grande amigo
ele então concluiu agradecemos bastante
o facto de considerarem o sustento ea
tensão e 1060 uma frase que a minha
imagem saber mais
só assim você não acha
[Aplausos]
[Música]
é
o i
[Música]
[Risadas]
ae
[Música]